so we made a few videos about relativity
and we've talked about how distances
change in relativity we talked about how
time changes in relativity
um so i thought i'd talk about something
which combines those two things together
which is how speed which is distance
divided by time changes in relativity
the previous videos we made we called a
gamma trilogy because they all had this
gamma factor in it
actually one of the interesting things
about the way speed transforms is that
the gammas all disappear they all cancel
out so there is no gamma in this game of
video
so we need to think about uh how you
measure speed
let's say distance divided by timer but
particularly how it changes depending on
what reference frame you're in so we
need to think about how
different people measure speed in
different reference frames and so the
classic kind of thought experiment you
might do
is you've got somebody on a train and
we'll call what you call this reference
frame s prime and they're going to roll
a bowling ball
along the train at some speed or other
and the train itself is moving so this
whole reference frame is moving if you
like
in this direction at some other speed v
and so the way on the train you'd
measure the speed is that you'd see how
far the ball in bowling ball had gone in
your reference frame
should we call this delta x how far it's
gone
prime because it's in your reference
frame and
at what time you know at some you'd
measure that at some time
delta t prime after you'd let go of the
ball and then you could actually measure
the speed in your reference frame of
that bowling ball is just how far it's
gone
divided by the time it took to get there
right that's the definition of speed is
how far something's gone divided by the
amount of time it took to get there is
the definition of speed
so that's in one reference frame so then
the question is what does the person in
this reference frame the other reference
frame see
and let's deal with the non-relativistic
case first okay so what what are they
going to measure
the distance that they'll measure that
that ball has gone is going to be
how far the bowling balls rolled away
from you plus how far you've moved down
the line
that extra distance how far the train
has moved depends on well that's
basically
how fast the train was going you're sort
of adding it all on top of each other
exactly that's all you're doing so that
that distance is
v delta t the train's going at some
speed v and it's travel for some time
delta t then the distance it's covered
is just the speed times the time it's
taken to do it
so now we can put all this stuff
together that says that
delta x is equal to so how far you see
the ball is having moved is
how far the train's moved plus how far
the ball has moved relative
to the train just the sum of the two and
we can rearrange this
in non-relativistic case to say that
let's just divide through delta x
divided by delta t
is equal to v plus delta x prime
divided by delta t and in this
non-relativistic case we don't have to
worry about different people seeing
different times so it doesn't matter
whether that's delta t or delta t
prime we can call it the same thing it's
all the same thing or we can rewrite
this again
that just says that the speed that you
see the balls moving is equal to v
so that's delta x by delta t plus the
speed
that the person on the train sees the
ball moving and that as you said is just
basically you are just add the speeds
right the speed at which the bowling
ball is moving is the speed that the
ball is moving relative to the train
plus the speed that the train is moving
relative to you right that's the
simple galilean transformation no
relativity
everything works sensibly in the way
we're used to it working
the reason why people get interested in
this is that one of the things that
everyone says in relativity is you can't
ever travel faster than light
and so one obvious question you could
ask is well why can't i just get to
travel faster than light by doing these
kind of additions in that is
supposing instead of rolling a bowling
ball the person on the train was
actually shining a torch
along the train then the torch beam
would be indeed be traveling at the
speed of light relative to them
and then if you ask well how fast would
the torch be then be traveling relative
to you well it would be the speed of
light plus the speed that the train's
moving away from you and that's faster
than the speed of light
exactly it's sorted unfortunately
relativity takes care of that and it's
not really the way that things work
so we need to start again but we need to
now do the problem properly with
relativity
is this your minute physics audition
professor unfortunately my
drawing is not quite up to the job i
suspect uh and then we've got the other
chaps in here moving along at some speed
v okay now
previously the formula we had said that
the distance the bowling ball is
down the line is equal to the distance
on
relative to the train plus how far the
trains moved
now what the extra factor that we
haven't put in yet is special relativity
and
as we saw before what special relativity
does is introduces these factors of
gamma
and so the this galilean transformation
that we had before
is a little bit modified by an extra
factor of gamma in front of it
gamma is one over the square root of one
minus v squared over c squared
and we have a whole series of videos you
can go and watch about gamma should you
wish to do so but then the other thing
we know about relativity is that not
only does the
distance depend on what appearance frame
you're in but actually the time depends
on
which what reference frame you're in and
so the
we need the equivalent transformation
for that so there are these things
called
lorentz transformations that's the first
of them and then this is the other
lawrence transformation we need
turns out these are the two lawrence
transformations you need
okay so now we can say okay so what's
the speed
as measured from the person who's
standing beside the track watching the
train go by
and we just do the same thing that we
did before we just the speed is just the
distance divided by the time so we can
just divide them
you know with delta x divided by delta t
is equal to now the gammas are going to
cancel because if we divide that by the
other we end up with the gamma on the
top and going around the bottom so we
can just cancel them out and i'll do a
little bit of tidying up i'll divide
top and bottom through by delta t prime
so i can just write this as
delta x prime over delta
t prime this is kind of the answer that
we wanted because delta x over delta t
is the speed of the bowling ball or
whatever it is that's being thrown along
the train as seen from the person per
signing standing beside the track
and delta x prime over delta t prime is
the speed as seen by the person on the
train
so i can re write that in terms of the
u's and u primes that we have before
this just says that u
is equal to u prime plus v
divided by one plus that's a u
prime again v over c squared
which is the final answer in the
non-relativistic limit
so the what we were looking at before
the galilean transformation so both u
prime and v
are small compared to the speed of light
that means this term is small so this
thing's just one basically
and that just says that the speed you
see is just the sum of the speed of the
ball relative to the train and the train
relative to you which is the answer we
had before so that's right
it kind of comes out right if things
aren't close to the speed of light but
okay but now let's do the
the more interesting case of actually
where the relativity really matters and
in particular let's go to the really
extreme case of actually instead of
rolling a bowling ball along train let's
shine a light beam along the train
so in that case u-prime the speed of the
whatever it is relative to the train is
equal to the speed of light
and let's see what happens when we put
that in there so in that case we end up
with
if u prime is equal to the speed of
light then
u is equal to u prime is just the speed
of light
plus v divided by
1 plus u prime is the speed of light cv
over z squared now let me just do a
little bit of playing around with this
so i'll rewrite the
top here as c
into one so pull that factor out plus v
over c
because if i multiply this out i just
end up with c plus c v over c which is
just v
so c plus v divided by
and then all i'm going to do here is
cancel the c over c squared so i end up
with
1 plus v over c
which you'll notice is just the same as
the term there so this is the same as
that which just basically means that
this whole thing is just equal to the
speed of light still so there's the
bizarre thing
that we've taken we've remember what
we've done here is said okay so there's
a light beam that's moving relative to
the train at the speed of light now if
you're watching from beside the train
what speed do you see that light beam
going at the answer is still the speed
of light you haven't actually added to
its speed at all
and i guess the physics behind it is
that actually you really have to worry
about
both space and time being changed by
what reference frame you're in which
means that not surprisingly the speed
that comes out at the end
is going to be changed in a slightly
strange way as well and it turns out
that relativity takes care of this
invariance of the speed of light that no
matter what reference frame you're
watching of light
beam travel from you'll always see it
traveling at the speed of light
is the universe wanting to keep things
at the speed of light and everything
changes to
cater for that or does everything change
all the time and the speed of light just
falls out of that
is it chicken or egg it's a very good
question and i actually really like your
first explanation that actually the
universe arranges things in such a way
that the speed of light always comes out
as the speed of light
and no matter how much you mess around
with things by trying to run away from a
light beam or run towards it
when you come to measure its speed
you'll always find that its speed comes
out as a speed of light
and everything else kind of adjusts the
distances and the times adjust in just
such a way so that when you come to
combine those distances in times
to measure a speed for a light beam it
will always come out as a speed of light
is there something that is important
about the speed of light being constant
and unchanging and
so what motivated einstein to come up
with all this in the first place
is he had this idea that the laws of
physics
should be the same whatever reference
frame you're in so if you're in a sealed
box there should be no experiment you
can do that will tell you whether that
seal box is moving at a constant speed
or is stationary
and in fact it's even in his view of
things a kind of a meaningless question
and what he also knew is that the speed
of light comes out from the laws of
electromagnetism
and so then the question is okay so but
in what
in what reference frame do those laws of
physics work and his argument is that
those laws of physics should work in
whatever reference frame you're in
which means that actually the speed of
light has to be invariant
if you believe that the laws of physics
are the same in all the different
reference frames
what if it hadn't been that way what if
the universe has said nah
that can be different for different
reference frames like would like would
you and i be ripped to pieces in some
cosmic rip or would the universe just be
a bit different and quirky like does the
universe benefit from the fact
this is what happens i get i mean it's
very hard
to construct a universe in which this
wasn't true
in retrospect it's hard to construct the
universe in which this isn't true bear
in mind that for example you know
all the other things that come from
relativity kind of flow from that so i
think famous things like e equals m c
squared
all flow from this invariant to the
speed of light and that means that
the equivalence of mass to energy is
actually a natural consequence of
relativity and so for example what
powers the sun
fusion converting mass into energy
wouldn't work
and if we weren't living in a
relativistic universe now you could
imagine
that the universe the laws of physics in
such a universe would come up with some
other way of generating you know energy
from fusion but the picture we currently
have of it really would be completely
different
and the quantity of the speed of light
the the speed that it actually is
does that matter like would the universe
be the same if the speed of light
had been halved or it was quite you know
if it was something close to the speed
we walk at
like does it need to be as fast as it is
to our human brains
so it comes out the laws of
electromagnetism um so it's to do with
how strong
electric fields are how strong magnetic
fields are
which are really just arbitrary
constants of nature as far as we know
which which i guess means that actually
the speed of light which is some
combination of these things is also an
arbitrary
law of nature the universe would be a
very strange place if the speed of light
were very much slower because of course
all these relativistic effects
that lead to all the weird things that
come out of relativity
we don't usually have to worry about
them in everyday life but if it actually
turned out that the speed of light you
know was walking pace
then all sorts of strange relativistic
effects would happen every time you walk
to the
post box you know it would be you would
have to worry about all the relativistic
time dilation and length contraction
effects so to be like if i go and post
this letter is it going to am i going to
die before i get there because
or yeah or will the will have all your
relatives have died of old age before
you get home again so yes
indeed it would be a very very strange
universe so the light instead of going
straight up and down follows a path like
that
so it has further to go from our
perspective that light's gone further
but also the speed of light is the same
in every reference frame